happy to have intact leave from
university of washington
it's gonna tell us about a work in
progress a structured sampling package
go ahead please yeah so this
i changed the title a little bit uh this
topic is basically describing
our effort on making a software for
sampling this is a genre with my student
ruchi and santos
yeah we have been working on this for
for maybe two years and
yeah it's still ongoing but
but i guess i can still talk about this
uh i cannot resist on making this slide
today is the lesson day and you probably
see a lot of news
involved predicting the chance of who is
winning
or maybe for cover lighting you have a
lot of
you have seen a lot of deals about
predicting
uh the the future number of patient or
something like that
but but how people come up with those
chart
so in general there is one generally to
do this uh
for example you can first come up with a
model with a bunch of parameters
then you collect a bunch of data if you
use
optimization then you can try to choose
the parameter to fit
the data the best but then if you
use optimization you just get
one outcome but often you want to know
the probability of certain outcome
then in that case you can for example
use base frame
to get you a formula for for each
parameter what is the probability that
will happen
and you can think sampling is a basic
tool to predict with uncertainty
and this is especially useful for for
this year
and in this talk i will focus on
oh yeah in this time i will focus on
this
form uh you want to sample from
exponential negative f
where f is congrats uh by the way if you
have any questions feel free to stop me
i only have
20 slides so there should be plenty of
time for questions
uh throughout the top end is the number
of verbals
so when you want to come up with a
software to do sampling then the first
thing you will ask is
how the f is given
if you went to the top i gave
two weeks ago maybe in that talk i'll
focus on the regime f
is given by oracle given x you can
compute the value fx this
topic is very well studied in tcs and
those algorithms in fact where we could
they are efficient and very robust
especially for low dimension case
for example you have this table of
running time people are making
improvement year after year
but unfortunately there is some believe
there should be some informatic lower
bound of this form no one know what is
the informatic lower bond
but we believe there should be a lower
bond at least you can prove
omega n but probably is worse than that
and currently the best is anchored
assuming kls conjecture
uh but even for any iteration you'll be
too bad for
practice because if you have a million
parameters and you need a million step
that will take forever in practice
so in practice people
more focus on this regime you assume you
can
access not just f you can also access
the gradient of f
then you come up with some algo to solve
this
and in this talk i will focus on an
regime
i call structure model namely f is
of a certain form and the problem is
given explicitly
for example if f is a quadratic function
then you can just given the matrix
directly
then then you will not get any
information
so in principle you have more
information you should expect your algo
is faster
uh one thing to highlight is both
problem is very well study
in commerce optimization
uh the reason we assume f is commerce is
beyond this case
we don't have too much theoretical
guarantee on this form
and also you should notice sampling is a
problem more general than optimization
for example if you want to minimize f
then what you do
if someone give your oracle to sample
then you can just sample from e to
negative
a million yeah maybe
some large number f x if you
are able to sample from this guy then
the solution x
will be a good approximation of the
minimizer so you should think uh
impressively inside all sampling algo
there is an optimization algo hidden
inside
so to understand what happening is good
to study the optimization case first
in optimization there is also study on
this form in this two different regime
again for the first order regime we are
given f
you can only access the function f by f
and greater than f
and there is many different algo for
example gradient descent
and there is many package based on those
algo
for example we use tensorflow
and in general the performance of those
algo depends on if the problem is well
condition
namely if you draw the level set of the
function
if the level set look very skilled and
those are
not they are bad condition and if the
levels have looked like a sphere then we
call that well condition
and and for for first order method they
are usually faster for
for those sphere shape
and for optimization they people also
study the structure
model for example one particular model
people study is this you
optimize a linear function over linear
constraint with a unique quality coding
those are linear programs uh
and example algorithm
integral method and there's many package
on this
and in general the performance depends
on if the
if the matrix a have certain sparsity
pattern
so it this depends on where is the long
zero of
a happens instead of the numerical
number of a
so this two is quite different whether
when they're good
what i want to argue is uh even though
nowadays
people is very focused on deep learning
so
all the software is really based on
first order
but i still want to highlight uh
both method is important even for a lot
of days
let me just give you a classical example
showcase why first order method is
limited for some form
uh all the first order method look like
this you first complete gradient at
certain point
and then you move the current part
according to gradient
using some formula but those method will
be very slow for
for example this form this is a
this is a very basic problem uh
the problem is just some of difference
of square
and let's say you know the first point
is zero this is one
and you try to use some gradient method
to solve it
then you start with the initial choosing
let's say you start with something like
this
then one thing you notice is uh when you
compute the gradient
the first step the only long zero in the
gradient will be this
or other coordinate because all the
label is zero
if you compute the gradient this the
gradient at this point will be zero
so naturally if you move according to
gradient this shouldn't move because you
don't see that coordinate at
all so you can see uh if you run
any first order method essentially the
the information is properly coordinated
by coordinate
so for this form you should expect your
lip end step to soften
and in general first of all the method
is low if your problem have large
diameter
diameter in the sense how the
information can propagate through the
gradient
if i have done a funny experiment let's
say n
is 10 100 000 and i use a good gpu to
solve it
using tensorflow you will take one hour
but if you
just give this bomb to matlab yourself
in 0.1 second
even for a 10 years old cpu so
uh yeah for some problem first of all
the
method is quite limited uh
now i will switch to the sample in case
for example in case uh similarly you can
characterize from into these two cases
for first order in optimization you have
gradient descent
and for sampling you have a lantern
dynamic
and essentially you can finish just
creating design but
each step you add some large to make
sure you're doing sampling
and similarly you have package
based on those algo there is many many
package on this and
and similarly the performance depends on
if the problem have
is well conditioned uh
you can ask the similar question for
structure form
and similarly you can define some
problem look like linear program
you sample from ah exponential
distribution over
over some linear constraint and the
equality costing
and yeah first and also you have
alcohol similar to until pawn there is
again just
running into a compass laws uh the only
difference is there is
maybe ten of thousands of paper on intel
font
but maybe there is less than 10 paper on
on this sampling case
so there is much less literature on this
and and you should expect the
performance depends on the sparsity
uh for people doing tcs you can think
those algo give you polynomial time
namely the running time only depends on
the input size
but those algo in general is suitable
normal time
the running time depends on the
numerical number in the input
and yeah basically there is no almost no
paper on this
and naturally there is no package so
apparently this could be a stop idea you
can write a package on this
so this is what we are trying to do yeah
we have been doing this for two years
and
yeah uh yeah the resell is promising but
we realized there is a lot of
because there is not too much research
we realize there is a lot of research we
need to done
in order to get the algae right
but let me first explain why people care
about this form
certainly you leave people solve this
form before you
write any program uh turns out this
problem
has many application let me just give
you one
in biology let's say you
consider the rhetoric each coordinate
will represent one chemical reaction in
your body
then certainly chemical reaction
satisfies a mass
conservation law so so you will satisfy
some in you caught uh equality
also certainly reaction should be larger
than zero so it also satisfies some
inequality
so essentially you can find we use reset
we live in some python and also you can
uh find out the description of this part
by reading the dna
so one one way some system biology
similarly your body is to sample from my
exponential distribution over a particle
uh yeah this picture is some some some
picture from wikipedia showcase
how the each chemical in your body and
how they react
and in reality the picture look more
like this
in your body there is many chemical
and there is a lot of people using this
to
to do a lot of different experiment on
your body but
in a computer so this is one
application now let me give you
more ml application
as you've probably seen a
logistic model and lasso is a popular
model in ml
uh one thing to notice is both models
for example this model uh you notice
this is a scale
and then this is just a scalar function
so so for both model you can write it
actually
in this way f is just some of scalar
function
but the fringe inside is some linear
function
and and one basic way to
learn the model is to sample from e to
negative f
this is how statistician do
but how you formulate this form into
this linear program form
do you see it
turns out what you can do is uh you can
set s i is a
i transfer x if you do this then you can
write it into a
linear matrix from ax equals to s
then now our goal is to sample from e to
negative
f i s
i subject to this constraint
now to make this linear you can create
actual variable y
you restrict y larger than f i
s i then you can prove this distribution
is exactly
same as sampling from e2 that is for f
so this is not exactly equality
constraint notice you have some f here
if there is no f here then this is
exactly the linear programs
but the essentially you can think
we're restricting the inequality
constraint by a two dimension
comma set the conversation is
s comma y where
y larger that f yeah i'm using mouse to
draw
that's why i can hardly write
and and and all the
algo for the lp casey is easy to extend
to the
to this case because you're just
changing a one-dimensional part to
converse that to two currently our
software can only handle this case
because we haven't nailed down the hour
from for lp yet
let me just try to highlight why
sampling is particularly difficult for
making a package different python can
solve our optimization problem why we
expect pi touch pole cannot do that
uh so this is a chris
uh
maybe some audience can give me an
answer how long does it take for
sunlight to reach
f this is related to sampling
so anyone can give an answer
like eight minutes the answer is
uh no matter what you say i will say you
is wrong
it is h minute from the surface to f but
from center to the f it takes ten
thousand
hundred thousand years uh
anyone know why
the reason is this uh at the center of
the sun
the the light particle is basically
moving like a body motion because the
density is too high so he is doing
broadly moving although the distance
from the center to the surface
is much shorter but because it is doing
brand motion it will take forever
yeah you can google it those are real uh
i see some people really passionate
about this uh
but anyway uh but you can look at the
cartoon
if you're a mr p you go from c o to n if
you want a straight line then you take
angular of time
but if you're junk you take n square of
time
and that's why you have this huge
discrepancy
similarly for example for optimization
uh for is known if
your problem have condition number k in
this part
in this story it's not important to
divide this but some measurement of how
difficult
the problem is then optimization can do
is grow copper step and for sampling
people believe carpet probably is the
best you can do
by the way this is still open problem
people still making progress and
we still don't get the answer yet
but in general you can imagine sampling
your slightly
squared running time of optimization
because of this sampling behavior
uh this is not a lower bond uh this this
this analogy could be totally wrong
maybe there is some small goal
of doing sampling beyond just doing
binary motion
uh but but one take away is i want to
say a bad algo with a gpu
could be a good algorithm for
optimization but a bad algo
with a gpu for sampling could still be a
bad algo because
it's just too bad here is any recent
sampling is difficult
uh for optimization we usually we can
take a very large step size
for example let's say gradient descent
in general you can take a step size like
one of the lipsticks constant of the
gradient
turns out for sampling is more
complicated first of all the algorithm
will be changed a little bit
each step you move according to gradient
but you
need to add the losses that you expose
the space
and then you need to do a step to ensure
the
the stationary distribution is correct
uh this is not important to this talk
but turns out what happens is you can
prove your little text step size like
one over n
times the ellipses gradient and if you
take anything larger than the
which then this step will never accept
any probability
so this is quite horrible
uh yeah so you in general sampling need
to take smaller step
and because this is prime moving small
step the effect will be even worse
because you're squaring that
step size and
now we switch to why i believe u2 pawn
will be a very good sampling algo
i'm not going to really teach wise in
two parts so i will just draw a picture
uh let's say you you are you're solving
a linear program
you can think in two part method is like
putting a positive charge on every
boundary and also at your current point
and then you release the point and then
let's say you optimize
over this direction then you go out
according to the gravity
with the charge and what important is
you practice usually you take less than
30 steps
or maybe it usually takes a lot many
steps according to the dimension
and for sampling you can define a
similar algorithm
instead of going to a certain direction
it's more like
doing brand emotion for some false field
under some phosphate
and if what our analogy about
sampling is why if the sampling out will
take square number of step
in the optimization case then it has a
thousand step
is not too bad uh
yeah uh precisely what our package
implement is this algo we do a reminder
homogenous
carlo method with metric given by hassan
of some
blood barrier uh there's too many terms
here so let me explain it carefully
by a picture i think now everyone
understand what
this algo is doing ah
i yeah i will i would explain few slides
later
but i will first give you some
experiment
so this is some film without this
package using github
currently is improvement using matlab i
know
people use python this day but we still
experimenting the algo will transition
to other language
later so let me uh
test it with some oh by the way uh every
every example i pick is hand presses the
other elbow
is really bad and our algorithm really
good i'm very honest about this
uh but here is a very happy
example uh
imagine your you have a sequence of x
your model is this every variable
is generated by the previous variable
plus a gaussian
scale and then we we observe the data x
one is zero
x d zero when we say i pick this
is because uh this if you write it
carefully it turns out this
the distribution of x just follows uh
multivariable gaussian distribution
so all the commercial software can solve
this
uh without changing the algo so it's
convenient
uh here is a picture of one sample look
like
uh this is the k and this is xk
because of the observation this is zero
this is
and the the the the sample is look like
a brand name bridge except i scale them
appropriately so here is
a part of our algo versus some other
commercial
software student told me
lampyro is one of the best commercial
software currently so you can see our
algorithm is slightly better than them
you see we will
improve the running time from 4
to 1.4 ah
i mean the exposure uh
yeah i suspect if there is still many
detail of the algo
can be nailed down i believe one day we
can make it to
more like x instead of x to some other
exponent
and the curve should be even lower
yeah but we are still implementing for
example your free transition to see then
at least the running time will improve
fire feel better
uh but one thing i want to point out is
uh you can think this is just a very
simple time series model is
there is many statistic models involve a
time series
but even for that simple time series
model if your dimension is large
existing software cannot really handle
it well
uh if they do condition the reason i
pick one over k here is to make the
problem you condition
uh if if if they are constant then the
existing software will look more like
look i guess it will look more like this
is more like x squared instead of x to
the four
but if you conditional like this then
they they
simply cannot solve
so this is more uh artificial
example so let me switch to a more
uh realistic example hold on
so i'm i'm kind of missing the context
here because you were talking about this
uh you know romanian uh
lagrangian hessian whatever sampler
is is that the i mean that's usually
good for polytopes there's no quality
there's only two linear constraints here
yeah there's no polygon positive view
there is a linear okay what happens is
at this point you define
s equals to x k minus
x k
i mean it's a bunch of linear
constraints yeah
yeah yeah yeah got it yeah in general a
lot of form
although they don't look like positive
you can transform me in that way
yeah and and this you you ran
like that like the this uh
hamiltonian whatever yeah yeah we run
that yeah
yeah we essentially yeah it's just you
download the
the package and right
yeah so the example we test is this one
uh the the this is how we
uh start a project and it wouldn't give
us a model of symbol of
human uh
associated three years ago roland gave
us a very large model of human
and they have a lot of chemical and
reaction and they asked us a question
how to sample from this portal
the reason they asked this is oh yeah
the matrix look like this
i joined here uh the reason they asked
us is because they
if they use their current software their
software is based on
something like km1 is a cord method
roughly speaking their software one
century to get one sample
so you shouldn't use it if you try to
use
any other commercial software all those
elbows simply cannot move
because the step size needs to be like
10 to negative 7
and then yeah again maybe you lit a
million years to
solve this form that's why we start
working on this project
currently our software only one hour to
get one sample
so the reason i suspect the reason why
current software have
real difficulty of this is imagine in
your body
each chemical reaction they happens in
in the way today is
very different for example oxygen may
do a lot of reaction but some other
obscure
chemical may the weight may be way
smaller
so this problem in some sense is very
ill condition
and that's why existence of x simply
cannot run
another benefit of our software is our
software is very robust
for example there is a famous uh
data set on polytope is led lib
our software can sample according to
inside any of those portal but if you
use
existing software they probably can only
handle maybe a few percent of the data
set
instead of all so this is very robust
so now i guess the this is small tcs
task so i should talk about what's
exactly the algo
uh yeah so our our goal is uh
i need to first explain what is hormone
in my monte carlo first
i should highlight all the commercial
software based on this
we are doing similarly so the
the idea is this in general the
difficulty of
designing mcmc for sampling is you need
to
make sure this the distribution is
preserved
for each step and in order to preserve
the distribution we need to do a filter
rank
and usually the filtering forces to take
very small step size
and and there is a very nice hmce
they extend the palm into one actual
one extra set of variable v you can
frequently use the velocity
uh instead of sample from e to negative
f you sample
from e to negative f plus lamb of
v notice if you can sample from this you
can get a sample from x by
ignoring the verbal v so this is just
the same form
uh the beautiful about this is the algo
you can think the algorithm is like this
i am drawing
xss and vss here in general you have
many variables here
in general this is n and different
dimension here
and different dimension here so you can
think
we have distribution i'm drawing the
this the level set of the distribution
so what the algorithm is each step
you count this signal on your x and you
draw the distribution on the direction v
this is very simple because fixing x
sample from v is just a gaussian
distribution so this step is very fast
now the key thing to always doing is
let's say you draw pawns here
now the what the algorithm is doing is
it trying to do a rotation
in the space the rotation
will preserve the distribution
uh in particular the
the it will do a map
mapping from xv to txv
for example this is x we then the new
point here is
t x v
and what happens is this map will
will maintain the h value
yeah it will move along the level set
and also we will preserve the volume
element say you have
some picture here after you move then
we'll move to some other
if you apply the map from this element
then you will move to an
element with the same volume so this map
preserve the density
and this method is defined by ode like
this
this is the hamiltonian dynamic
uh and you can prove
uh if you solve this od and move to
time equals to one so you so you start
at
xv you solve this ode to move
and then you stop at a certain time you
can prove this map will preserve the
density of the distribution
so this is the algo each step you
fix x and zero according to v
then you solve for audi to rotate
along the space and then you would pick
and the beautiful about this algo is
if you solve the od exactly you don't
need to
do the filtering step you can prove the
algorithm preserve the density
so you can take a really really large
step size the elbow will still
recall at and also we know how to solve
ode efficiently
that's why this is a very good algorithm
uh but this album is slow
when the distribution is is not well
conditioned if the distribution
is this turns out this algo is still
slow
uh you can think the previous algorithm
picking v according to a standard
gaussian distribution and roughly
speaking it will move
along the direction we what we do is
we sample from a long statement gaussian
instead
then then the the algorithm will look
like this
the the expression the formula change
because you want to sample from a long
gaussian
you can check you can check this formula
if you
we check on we you you if you fix
x then the distribution on v is just a
gaussian distribution
according to a matrix g
and in general we'll pick different g
for each
different point so this is the remaining
hmc
the algorithm is exactly the same except
we are changing the formula of h
and turns out if you compute the
derivative of h
it just involves solving some linear
system so this algo is still easy to
implement
it just involves solving some linear
system
uh and remember our problem have some
constraint we have some ax equals to b
constraint so you need to pick your
magic
on that subspace and yeah you define
think carefully such that uh
mcmc always preserve the constraint
then turns out what you do is you just
respect the universe by
pseudo-inverse and determine by
determinant
again the algorithm is exactly the same
except i change the formula h
again but now the if you compute the
derivative of
actually it will involve
pseudo-determinant
you can do that by svd
this is lower
um but what is the metric we pick
if for example if the constraint is x
larger than zero
you can think let's say the problem is x
is here
you want to pick the magic such that the
distance from any pawn to
any other pawn is kind of small you
then one natural choice of matching is
the bronchi metric
every point to the other pawn have diff
distance
roughly the same up to a lot term
uh if you pick this metric and then
substitute the previous formula you can
simplify the equation a little bit and
get some
explicit formula now the formula the sun
involves the determinant so now
all suduelus is gone and there's no svd
is needed
and also you can prove this algorithm is
uh
invariant under many transformation
for example i remember if you multiply a
bar
remember you have a constant ax equals
to b
i think if you multiply both sides by
some matrix
the algo will be still the same
or if you scale x by some some scalar
you'll be still the same
and in general you can prove this algo
take for a long time
uh so it's independent if you if you
duplicate the same constraint two copies
then it's not
yeah we yeah and turns out in practice
we found some political we are very slow
and we are still trying to fix it
there is some way to handle that but
usually those rate is very
expensive to implement in practice
that's why we are still
trying to look for a better way to
handle that issue
yeah i was like in general you could
like take
assign a weight to each constraint kind
of like how much this constraint matters
to do that but yeah but we're still
struggling on how to make that practical
yeah by the way uh just to remind you
in general how you solve linear system
uh
in practice matrix is usually sparse say
this is the matrix you want to solve i
call this
is m oh i saw some chat
how does c3 is dealt with
oh you know someone asked uh
for the duplication of coursing is how
people
solve handle this issue in lp for pre
in practice and somehow in practice
somehow they don't have this issue
that's why i still understanding why it
happens in sampling
but not lp
ah
yeah let's say you have matrix m
and you in general people
solve the linear system by doing a
character in resisting those triangle
matrix
and if you represent your matrix by
triangle then
it's easy to solve for triangle and
universe is just
l like you just solve two triangle
system
so the difficulty is how we will do this
decomposition
uh if you do it lively usually you get a
dance matrix so the running time is
horrible
but turns out impressive usually you can
reorder the rubble in certain ways
that the chassis the position is sparse
and yeah this is some example
those likely point of if you do charge
he was the running time
honestly i'm really stunned by this this
example uh
i in general don't believe this excel
crop fitting
so this curve here this is the palm size
in terms of number of laws so this is
the running time
i'm using nanosecond you can see what is
the running time
according to excel seems to running the
time is very closely linear
yeah uh but but i remember
when i was undergrad i was doing
scientific computing
and people in that area like to say it
is very difficult to beat matlab for
solving linear system even i define a
very smart album for my particular poem
yeah and and they also like to say yeah
the running time is
quite close to linear in practice
and so suffering in this system is
really not a problem for
us uh also if you look carefully
in in our hamiltonian formula there is a
lot determined
turn so you can compute log gradient of
log determinant by taking
auto differentiation on the charts key
algo so you can still do it very
efficiently
yeah and that is roughly what we do in
the algo
the real difficulty is just to implement
it
we expect there should be roughly 100
times
improvement is possible on this form
the first thing we want to fix later is
exactly
what roland said uh turns out there is
some part of this many
redundant counting and now magic is not
ideal for those python
and yeah we still haven't figured out
what is the
buried well is the metric that is easy
to compare and use faster
another thing we want to study is how to
solve the linear system faster
certainly is uh the reason is
this problem is quite special we are
solving the linear system
again again just the micro value change
but the sparsity pattern is same for all
the linear system
inside the algo so maybe we can take
advantage on them and get a better
linear system software
currently we are doing a very live ote
software we are just using a implicit
art
currently our algorithm is based on
implicit oil
this is basically the most life algo
out there so we believe that it should
be a better algol
we can use and this is probably why in
our
experiment the running time is n to the
one
point four instead of one we know if you
use this algo you cannot get linear you
need higher order od software
and yeah certainly in other people to
use really to generalize beyond portal
and then the problem become more and
more system-ish
there is many problems there we should
auto-tune
we didn't implement the algo quality
according to the cpu architecture this
mod
for example we didn't use multi-core
uh we didn't use gpu and we didn't use
very complicated compiler technique so
we believe
our algo should be way faster although
our album is already
super fast currently but yeah but we are
still trying to make sure our algorithm
is robust that fast
and in general we believe your sampling
should be
you can make my general belief is you
can software
you can sample maybe as fast as 10
times of the cost of solving a linear
programs
and we're still quite far away from that
that
goal yeah but yeah
but honestly my my reasoning is not
implementing all of those
if you think about all the commercial
software they have a huge company behind
them for example
the one we compare against that is done
by uber and tensorflow is done by google
and certainly i don't want to spare 100
years on this project
and my really hope is some statistician
or some some partitioner can pick up
from this project
instead of i try to convince them
yeah that's it any questions
yeah nikki
oh yeah i have a question where did the
the hessian show up
question oh you mean
where is oh what do you mean by hessian
i think at some point you mentioned uh
oh
hash okay okay sure
uh more precisely for this question we
use the metric is pong kai metric
but but for a more general comma set
we use the metric given by hessian of
some function
what is fine uh let's say your
your point top is this frame then we
define a function file says that it blew
up on the bungie
then we use the hexane of that that
function
i think yeah
other questions
so if if it blows up really close to the
boundary only really close then
practically what you do is just billiard
like the hamiltonian flow is just
billiard yeah do you know
if is there are there some
like nice conditions on the polytop for
which
billiard is effectively as good as what
you're doing
like i don't know suppose it's like
isotropic
or you know the trouble is this uh
for for my algo you can prove let's say
for a hybrid coupe
the running time will just involve
probably lost them
but for brilliant i think you will
essentially to touch the
constraint end times at least i don't
know
i don't know what is the lower bound for
brilliant for
hypercube
probably for hypercube it's pretty good
right i mean
uh but at least you should expect you
should take n step
i don't know yeah uh
yeah then n step is already
difficult to implement
yeah for example uh in in my experiment
here
although i didn't write down the lump of
iteration for our algo
we take 20 to 40 iteration
for example even for
very large dimension
yeah so that's yeah
and i guess one more question so
i mean this this only makes sense if
like the density is
the indicator of some polytops times e
to the
like an x linear like a log linear
function
but if like if your function
is you know not concave and not log
linear
but you know maybe not not like
too low concave maybe let's just say
piecewise log linear
and low concave can you still do
something
by using like uh
usually you can by introducing newer
to right into a form that look more like
this
usually you can write down into a form
axis given by
pattern of small dimension comma set
sorry can you repeat that usually you
can for example with this two poem they
have
nothing related to poetry
but by introducing some new level then
it becomes a part of
is right yeah and usually you can do
that for many problems yeah but
often i'm asking about you know you want
to end up with a long linear potential
in this body though yeah but but for
example this
or which is that the the the
density is not linear
we reformulate to a linear
yeah in this case because it's
two-dimensional
then you can easily like approximate it
by
i agree but i mean i'm i'm just asking
you know
i mean i agree that this captures a lot
of cases already
oh yeah but but in general then you can
do self-concordance
very i mean i mean technically
sampling from this is same as sampling
from
a comma set uh
sure yes and then and then you just put
people use this just log f if you have
yeah let's say for the set f larger than
zero
one one one barrier people use in
practice is just not f it will not be
self-concurrence
but sometimes it still works
yeah i don't know for this this
sampling whether it will work if i just
do that
cool thanks
okay any additional questions comments
uh if not let's thank entirely for a
nice talk